greetings it's wednesday the 24th of
february the joint
is brought to you by expressvpn let me
ask you a question
when you use the bathroom do you close
the door behind you
you don't want people looking in on you
right so why would you let people
see what you look at online using the
internet without expressvpn
it's like going to the bathroom and not
closing the [__] door did you know
that the creepy internet providers
actually spy on what you do every single
website you visit
and then they turn around and sell you
info
to ad companies is that what you want
let me tell you something
sometimes at night when i go deep deep
deep into the murky waters of the
underworld
i got an express vpn and i go to places
and i look at things you've never seen
before
i don't like talking about them because
nobody's business but anyway
express vpn puts a stop
to the madness it creates a secure
tunnel between you
and the internet so if you're like me
and believe your online activity
is your own [__] business secure
yourself
by visiting expressvpn.com
joey again expressvpn.com
joey and get an extra three months free
free three months for free support the
joint
and protect your [__] privacy people
they're out there
they're doing this constantly it's time
now to get this today right now
go to expressvpn.com
joey and start protecting what you watch
the church is also brought to you by cbd
lion i can't say enough things
about cbd lion all i can say
is that i'm too down to a half a pillar
pain pill
a night before i go to bed all day and
then
that jarred the jar is full because of
cbd line my surgery has been
very successful with the help from the
tinctures
to the to the to the kinesiology tape
to the tincture to the gummy bears to
the vapor
what however you want see uh cbd
cbd line will provide it for you but you
got to do me one favor first
you got to go to cbdlion.com that's
where the party starts
read read learn
what cbd can do for you
go to cbd line right now right now.com
check out what they got the bath walls
the kinesiology tape
the vapor however you want the gummy
bears are from another [__] planet
the raspberry ones are from another
[__] planet so
start today go to cbdline.com you don't
want to buy your cbd lion from some
[__] mud at the
corner store or something why would you
buy cbd
at a [__] liquor store i saw cbd
liquor store the other day
i'm like are you [__] crazy
cbdlion.com right now
slash showy get 20 off your order
delivered right to your [__]
house let's get this joint started
[__]
it's wednesday
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 24th of february i
got no snots in my nose today
everything's beautiful let's start off
by thanking governor murphy
right now [__] governor newsom is
getting darts thrown at that [__]
but my governor murphy is on the ball
and [__]
we smoked the number yesterday we
[__] got it all out of the way so
it's legal in new jersey
so for all you haters that were [__]
uh talking [__] in the beginning and
goofing on me
we could smoke it wherever the [__] we
want i don't want to smoke on the
podcast because
i've been smoking on podcasts for the
last [__] 10 years what's another
joint go smoke a joint by yourself
[__]
but anyway it's a beautiful day to be
alive [__] uh
something happened today i'm gonna
target your heartstrings again
cause this tugged at mine i've been
thinking about this for a while
and uh again i let life throw me [__]
signs
you know i could come in here like i
said until we get things going
and the numbers are going down in new
jersey i think it's zero
eight eight point transmission so things
are starting to [__]
uh whatever i'm trying to get the kid
needle
over at cvs to get a shot you know i'm
trying to put the pieces together but
that's not why we're here today uh i'm
excited about tonight doing some
stand-up
my leg feels better i heard it the other
day but i went to the doctor monday
after the podcast and [__] uh
i went to therapy and they just said i
just pulled a little [__] muscle
the knee is good so i'm good you know
what i'm saying yeah a muscle it was
just a little muscle you put a little
heat on it i put ice
and that's it what the [__] you want
from me you smoke reefer that's what we
do you want to heal
a little cbd lion some reefer but what i
want to talk to you guys about was
something that happened on sunday in my
house here
and uh it's gonna someday it's gonna
blow up eventually
you know i don't know when it's gonna
blow up in my face
uh sunday we
i went for a ride i had to run some
errands my daughter and
i should have talked about this on
monday but i saw the
law and order on monday night and that's
what made me put this whole thing
together
uh sunday afternoon my daughter and my
wife went
tubing last weekend in pennsylvania with
a bunch of moms
they had a great time you know my
daughter's having a great time here
that was the whole thing of me moving
was for her and she's living the life of
[__] riley here
so they went tubing and it was weird
because saturday night i had a show
and i didn't really think about it you
know when i got there i looked at the
time it was eight o'clock when i got to
uh uncle vinnie's and then i said you
know what they usually go to bed around
30. let me call them now and just say
good night why call my wife she's like
what we're at the [__] pool
we're at the pool these listen to them
and they were jumping up and down
so at 9 30 when i got off stage i talked
to the owner you know i talked to jim
florentine for a couple minutes and then
my nephew drove me back and on the way
home
my wife called and she goes i just want
you to know we're in the hotel
you know uh we're gonna take showers and
stuff and you can call us whenever you
want whenever you're ready
like okay i'm just i'm on my way home i
should be home 20 30 minutes whatever i
don't [__] know what i told her
i come home that night i walk up the
stairs blah blah blah
i you know make my tea i put my [__]
capsules in it to go to sleep i was
already go to sleep
and all of a sudden the phone rang i
thought it was too late to call them i
go you know by now they're probably
asleep
the phone rang at like 10 30 maybe 10 45
and it was my wife and she goes my
daughter your daughter wants to say good
night
and when she was saying goodnight to me
it was weird she was like good night
daddy and i'm like good night mercy and
i
i didn't think about it at the time i
watched the night you know i was
watching the honeymoon
something i was i taped the 9 30
honeymooners and i was watching them
because then they come out at 11 11 30.
so i was watching the 9 30 honeymooners
and i was you know i was paying
attention to the honeymooners i was
talking to her at the same time and she
just
kind of said i love you daddy miss you
i'll see you tomorrow okay go ahead i'll
see you tomorrow and my wife goes listen
when i come
until later because we're gonna get up
and go to the pool at nine we're all
gonna meet
eat breakfast and go to the pool at nine
i go tremendous that's even better let
her
get her [__] yayas out what you gonna
do in the neighborhood
it's just cold here you know so i do
what i got to do on sunday i run
submarines i go to my buddy's house my
goomba's house we smoke a number i come
back
i'm sitting on the thing i got ice on my
leg i'm minding my own [__] business
and i hear the garage door open and i go
the girls at home you know
and uh sure enough a couple minutes
later i hear the door open up and
it's my daughter and she's walking
towards me
and she's [__] bawling right and i'm
like
uh what happened was if she sits on a
certain side
when she opens the door she always hits
my car with the door
and my wife says something to her you
know she's [__] ate
you know she doesn't know she doesn't
understand
the concept i showed her the dent and
she apologized
and you know that was it so i saw her
coming towards me crying and i go
what happened i thought she was gonna
tell me i dented the car mommy's mad at
me
she [__] dropped her stuff and
ran to me and i was on the reclining
chair
she just i mean guys she just dropped on
me
and started crying and i go what's the
matter mercy what happened is mommy mad
at you what happened
and she goes i've really missed you
daddy i really miss you i don't ever
want to be
without you again i i i didn't like it
when you
used to leave and do comedy on the
weekends but i knew
you were making money for the house but
ever since we've been in jersey i don't
want you to go out no more
i missed you a lot i don't uh she goes i
don't even like being without you
uh on you know next time we go on a
family vacation we all have to go
together
and guys she was glued to me the rest of
the day
i guess it's traumatized that you know
we've been together for the last [__]
year
but the last year we have not been apart
at any law at all i've been with them
every [__] night
for a year now since february 29th
of last year she's been with me every
[__] night
eight o'clock we watched bunks and
[__] jesse
trust me i watch all those shows i know
you're looking at me going joey you're
[__] when you have a daughter or a
kid
you got to watch those shows that's time
you know so i don't
watch them all day with her so we have a
window her shower's at 7 30
and then from eight to nine she watches
jessie and bunked
and sometimes i let her stamp till 9 15.
like i play the attorney for
i say mom she did her homework because
she hit the mitts
let her [__] stay up till 9 15 and
she stays with me but this is
what has happened like uh she was like i
just don't
want to be without you and i'm like
this is [__] weird you know okay
whatever it is she's eight she's
a young girl and i'm gonna fulfill her
wish you know okay you want me to stay
i mean she doesn't mind me doing comedy
or whatever but i think she just wants
me in the house
i have a process with her every night
she comes down
we eat dinner we all go to our separate
corners she finishes homework or does
one of the programs to learn math or
spanish
and then we all jump in showers
everybody has their own show
you know i got my little manscape cave
and uh
mama's got her bath and mercy's got her
shower
and then we hook up again around ten to
eight we hook up
we sit down either in the living room or
in the family room downstairs and we
watched
whatever those kids shows are you know
bunk jesse
uh i don't even know and i you know i'm
high half the time so i'm sitting there
watching them stone
giggling oh big city greens
i [__] i [__] love big city greens
you know
all those [__] i want that when you have
kids that's part of the time
i mean she sits right on me and we watch
this thing and
that's our schedule at night and then at
9 15 she goes up
i give her about 20 minutes and i go up
there
while she's still falling asleep i kiss
her
i tell her god bless her in spanish that
your grandparents are watching over you
and i grab her foot i always touch a
foot i have the same process every night
i come down i hang with my wife then
when my wife goes to bed i walk my wife
up
back up there and i go in the room and
check on her again and pull the cover on
and make sure she's okay
and throughout the night i'll go in
there like if i wake up at three in the
morning first place i had is to my
daughter's room
to check up on her make sure she's okay
the bed
the teddy bear the whole [__] thing
so now that we got through with that one
i had to tell you that
to get to the other one it's like 16
minutes the other night they were
telling a story about the judge
who uh uh got her husband and son got
shot in uh
new brunswick east brunswick the supreme
court judge in august
yeah it was on 60 minutes and she was
just explaining how
you know judges need to have privacy you
know i didn't know judges got
[__] threatened like that listen and
me and my wife were talking about this
i go i'm a [__] felon and
never ever even thought of threatening a
[__] judge
that's that's listen i'm a [__]
convicted felon been to prison
i've never threatened a judge i've never
had a problem with a [__] police
officer except
one i've never raised my hand to an
officer one time
the guy that arrested me not jimmy colar
i give him props and boulder his partner
didn't like me and i didn't like him and
that that happens in life
but any other cop i look at cops driving
me to [__] uncle vinnie's either
retired cops
active duty cops every [__] tuesday
it's either my nephew
or my [__] best friend or my other
[__] best friend that's a cop an nypd
cop
so every week you know i like cops i got
nothing against them
but i suppose they get like [__]
hundreds of thousands of threats
but when they were telling the story
about the the spanish judge
they had to go into the other story
about
trump how he tweeted uh
something about a supreme court justice
about uh
blocking the [__] travel ban or
something
and now with the kind of threats he was
getting he had to go to a restaurant
with a bomb sniffing dog
like i would never even dream of
threatening a [__] judge i [__]
see a judge i would give him the utmost
respect because
they have applied themselves to the law
something that i
[__] dream i would have applied
myself to but i you know how i
am [__] sticking to laws but uh
i respect that there's some part of me
being a cop
being a fireman there's some part of me
as a cuban
i don't know what it is being an
immigrant that i got the utmost respect
for [__] judges
but that's not my point my wife was mad
because she goes why they have to throw
trump into this and i go because they
had to use that to explain the story
so back to monday night monday night me
and mike do the podcast monday
monday night i'm sitting downstairs and
i'm watching [__] uh
law and order the regular one i don't
watch svu i don't like that svu
i did an episode but i didn't [__]
like it because they talk about rapes
and [__] like that so it bothers the
[__] out of me
so i am waiting on
law and order organized crimes you know
you're gonna see me on one of those
[__] episodes or many of those
[__] episodes i'm gonna try to get on
that [__]
as soon as possible if anybody knows the
producers or whatever let them know
uncle joey's [__] interested
in law and all the organized crimes i'm
ready to go i'll play whatever they want
me to play greasy joe
fat tony i don't give a [__] at this
point let's bring it on
anyway so sometimes when you tell a
story
you gotta show an example or something
else and tell a great story you want to
see a great storyteller
[__] sammy the bull gravel that's a
great storyteller but anyway
monday night's episode of law and autumn
you know they play 82
000 of them i've seen 84 000 of them
and i've seen each episode 20 000 times
but sometimes we just sit there across a
bridge to wait
for like i'm dying up here or something
to come on we'll watch the tail end of
the lawn on and it was about a girl that
uh wanted to reach out to her father her
father and her mother had had an affair
and she had gotten pregnant
and she wanted to reach out to her
father and the father was now married he
had a child of his own he had his own
family
and he didn't want nothing to do with
her you know and i thought about my
situation
with my dog i mean listen for me to move
on
like i've mourned my daughter quicker
than i mourned
ralphie because with my daughter the
quicker i moved on from my daughter
the quicker i mean it was just holding
me down the pain
but i still think about every day i know
i lied to you people and tell you that
in my mind she's dead you know i'm lying
to you that
she still crosses my mind every day at
some point of the day
and once a month i look her up on social
media
just to look at her you know i don't
reach out i don't
uh i don't cross the line i respect her
you know whatever she wants she doesn't
want to talk to me that that's something
that i have to deal with you know
but what really amazes me about my
daughter the other day that i didn't
understand
is that for the first time in my life
if you see me and i look good and i look
happy and i'm having a good time
i got something for the first time in my
life that
for years i mean i'm not i'm not you
know your mind
is the strongest [__] weapon in the
world okay your mind is so [__]
strong
and you have to learn to control your
mind and sometimes it is mental illness
sometimes it is mental awareness
awareness
but sometimes you your mind could take
you
into [__] deep holes and you
like the you know walk i don't know
minecraft
warcraft i don't know my daughter plays
some game and some guy told like me not
to let her play it
because it takes you to different levels
do your mind works the same way
you know let me just give you this
example i know we've been talking a lot
about it but i have to give you this
example to understand
you know so my my father dies
my mother dies in 84 my uncle pretty
much rejects me whose blood
in 84 my godfather pretty much rejects
me
he asked me to sell coke and
in i don't know 2004
my daughter decided she wanted to disown
me also
you know so i'm coming from a place
where in your mind
if you really want to be feel you know
like if you really want to feel bad for
yourself i got every right to do so
and say that nobody wanted me i mean
nobody wanted me at the end of the day
my mother [__] took off
my dad took off you know they saw me at
the hospital my dad's like i'm not
putting up with this big foot
big foot big eared [__] my
mother took off my uncle told me to go
[__]
myself and granted i'm straight with my
uncle today and we love each other daily
i spoke to him last night you know my
godfather he could burn in [__] hell
last i heard from him he's in boca raton
or one of those
the keys for years i thought of going
down there and stabbing him in the
[__] lung but what would that do
you know my daughter doesn't want me you
know my ex-wife
won't whatever so part of me
always has felt as a rejected person i
mean
if you really look at it you have to be
you have to be real with yourself from
time to time
and look at the [__] what's in front
of you you have to say to yourself
nobody wanted me nobody that was my
blood wanted me
you know and yet now i talk to my
cousins and
you know and listen my cousins came into
my life
way before any of this thing started my
cousins came into my life from like
2009 right after i got married my two
cousins
raised their hands they came to the
comedy store no
i met them at the improv i got a call
from the improv
that they had seen my name on the gazebo
i wasn't even at the store
then so my cousin's here i'm in touch
with my cousins now and
you know i got a little successful after
i met my cousins they're very successful
eki and emma and i talk to them we're
still tight today i'm tight with all my
family members
but for a couple of [__] years there
i walked around
knowing deep down inside that nobody
[__] wanted me
and i know a lot of you people that
watch this show or
listen to the podcast whatever have at
some point you know i felt that
way you know my ex-wife didn't want me
you know
after a while it wears on your [__]
soul i don't care
how [__] tough you are you know and
and you know what i'm happy it happened
because it toughened me up for comedy
it toughened me up for comedy getting
used to it a lot of people
you know it's very hard
to start comedy but it's very easy to
quit
because the rejection nobody likes to be
rejected
it's at any level whether it's a date
whether it's a piece of gum you know if
i come up to you and go let me bump a
smoke go [__] yourself
what you know nobody likes to be
rejected so for a long
time i felt really [__] rejected
you know the first time i felt like i
belonged
to a society was when i became a
comedian
but besides that i always was a [__]
lost soul
once i became a comedian and mitzi short
took me in
and my wife took me in i still had those
feelings that nobody wanted me
i still had those feelings that nobody
wanted me but they had settled down over
the years
when i got married in 2009
that settled it down a little bit you
know
as things went on then my daughter was
born
that settled a little bit but i still
have these
from time to time i'm just human
just like you guys i'm a sinner you know
uh i cut when i bleed you know and i put
my pants on one leg at a time just like
you
i have emotions and i have shortcomings
and i have you know and we all have them
some people don't want to acknowledge
him i have made a career i have made a
life
out of acknowledging my weaknesses
so i can make myself a better person
i've always tried to be a better person
but unless you look at your weaknesses
with an honest [__] view
it's not going to [__] pan out for
you so for me i was just trying to be
honest with myself
nobody [__] wants me you know i got
to figure something to [__] out
you know so that's why i think comedy
came in i mean
as a kid my mother was a great mother to
me
a great mother but in my mind after she
died like i said
the mind is a powerful [__] machine
and if you start adding [__] adderall
and that all that anxiety medication to
it
that's why the mind is a power machine
people hang themselves whatever
i don't know i'm not i don't know i'm
not a specialist on it
but just alone the mind
is a [__] powerful machine because
they'll take you and put you into a
corner that you don't even know you're
going in
you're painting yourself into a corner
that's why you always have to be on top
of your mental health
you always have to check yourself [__] i
watch these podcasts you know i sit down
i watch them and i'm like i'm not right
today i feel good today i feel tip top
[__] my goal i had a good night's
sleep
i thought [__] monday i was gonna go
to [__] the doctor and the doctor was
gonna tell me i needed another surgery
there was just so many [__] things
you know i'm not i got my relief banned
on you know me dog
i'm happening i'm happy i'm ready to go
but
for years i felt very very very
very rejected and then
mercy was born and
like i told you [__] [__] you
i i'm you know i got a
i have to show you that i'm strong so i
have to say that yes
i i you know jackie's gone my older
daughter's gone there's nothing i could
do
i don't you know she's dead to me but if
you know anything about my heart and my
soul you know i'm lying to you guys
you know that i think about where she is
every day at one point of the day it's
not like i cry
i'm not gonna [__] you no i just
think
and once a month i do go and check on
her social media
once a month maybe once every other
month i google her
to see what she looks like today you
know the last picture i googled of her i
could see
my cheeks in her face and my smile
doesn't hurt
no it feels like a finger in the ass
yeah
it [__] hurts it hurts all the way to
the core of my soul
but the higher power threw me
a consolation prize and i have to accept
it because
she's more than a consolation prize
she's my heart that little girl
so when she ran in here the other day
and just jumped on top of me
and fell like that and i mean her weight
was dead on my chest i had ice on my
knee i'm like what the [__]
she was just dead and the tears were
pouring from her eyes
and i was you know just i just held her
and her mother came in and the mother
looked at me and went
you don't know and then when she went
upstairs the mother told me she goes it
started about 9 30 last night
she could have started on the hill she
said she wished daddy would have came
just to watch that she knew i couldn't
[__] go down the tube
because of my knee but she was then
about 9 30 came
and she remembered the honeymooners and
that's your date night
and it was [__] off the charts from
that in my heart
yes i feel [__] special as [__]
that my daughter loves me and so i had
to
write her you know i journal to her too
that's another one of my [__] many
[__] jobs
i journal i try to journal taran this
journal i wrote it was listen man
if you're gonna freak out about me you
know if you're reading this
i'm done if you're reading this [__]
journal it's because i'm [__]
kapoot's
this weekend you went skiing or tubing
whatever the [__]
you were gone for one night and you came
back crying i appreciate the love
and i appreciate the tears and stuff but
if you're reading this i'm gone and if
you cried over me being gone one [__]
night
you're gonna lose it like i did when my
mother died when your grandmother died
i go so keep it the [__] together all
right
get it together you know i love you this
is why i write on this journal
you know i [__] love you you know i
care about you're not gonna have any
doubts
not like me i sit here today wondering
what the [__] happened with my mother
she's not gonna have those doubts
because as soon as i [__] punch the
ticket
and they throw me in the incinerator i
wasn't gonna get buried and go through
the whole thing and [__] that
i don't want no creepy funerals no more
after that last fruit
i went to that sit now they put a net
over here you gotta hold your hand no no
no
just burn me and then you gotta go i
gotta go visit the grave every month
i gotta go now when the [__] snow
clears and i'm digging my mother up
there cause that's gonna cost me a
[__] arm and a leg up there to
[__]
no just just burn me after they burn me
they're gonna give her a box
and it's gonna have all the notebooks
that i've written journaled to her
so she knows all my feelings how i felt
throughout
me being her dad and her growing up
she's gonna know from the videos
i you know that i'm not too proud of but
you know what are you gonna do about
that
she's gonna see the video of me and
rogan get in trouble she's probably
gonna giggle you know
she's gonna see all these things but
she's also gonna read that
journal and reading and seeing is two
different things
and appreciating she's gonna appreciate
i wrote that journal
i wish my mother would have wrote a
journal to me thank i want to give a
shout out
to jack stella from sons anarchy to
turning me on
to writing a journal to his kids i
thought that was the most brilliant
[__] thing
i ever saw in my life he used to write a
journal to his kid or
i wanted to give a shout out to the
creator but for right now
jax teller [__] did it first when i
saw jax tell it
i'm like that's exactly what i got to do
and you got to be that honest with them
in the journal
write that journal for your kid this is
not now you're like [__] you joey
[__] you first i gotta write a journal
for me every day now i gotta write one
for my kid
you want your kid to walk around when
you're dead like a [__] mama
you ever see these kids they walk around
my father died
like i did i was a [__] [__] when
my mother died
i was making stories up in my head that
i was going to get a half a million
dollars from somewhere
that there was a hidden will in my head
you know
that's what happens to kids when your
[__] mother dies young and you don't
have a support system
and you don't have somebody to tell you
the [__] truth around you
it took five years for somebody to tell
me the truth i didn't want to [__]
accept it i almost shot him my uncle
we almost went to war i don't want that
to happen to my daughter i want my
daughter
to know what happened every [__]
step along the goddamn way do you
understand me
i'm sorry i'm thirsty i've been talking
too much and i'm saying but
it just really shocked me that
for the first time ever like
and besides you guys i mean listen you
guys are my family you guys come to the
shows
you applaud and all that and that filled
up that probably filled the big void in
my heart
you know i mean we all do something for
a reason
i mean uh i've turned this podcast the
last three weeks into something
since we have all this time on our hands
it's a great time to self analyze
yourself
and see what's going on what's not going
on what's going wrong
this has been a [__] tremendous this
is
it's i hate this pandemic
for taking lives i hate this pandemic
for shutting schools
i hate this pandemic for a lot of things
but this pandemic has a silver lining to
it
everything always does in the life this
pandemic
has a silver lining because every day
during this pandemic
i have gotten stronger and better yeah
my comedy skills went down
maybe as many people aren't watching the
podcast as they used to
maybe i'm not as funny as i am no more
but i have changed i have truly
changed my thoughts my way of thinking
you know how i look at things
and i see how other people have changed
their ways of thinking i'm watching what
has gone on
in a regular world that wouldn't happen
to tom segura
i just got a call from a dear friend of
mine that has been on a
podcast tom rhodes had an incident in
his life i mean he's okay
uh you know i'm not going to talk his
business but
you know he had something happen to him
that would never happen to somebody in a
lifetime
so the world yes it's on its access but
this gives you a time to
just one hour a day i don't want you to
[__] dwell on it
for eight hours like a jerk off you know
mike got me a guitar i want to thank
mike i bought a big round of applause
my brother mike got me a guitar you know
i told
mike goes we'll do some lessons i go
mike right now
my head is not for lessons so the other
night i went on youtube
and i pressed in guitar lessons holy
[__]
holy [__] i feel like a [__] [__]
because i mean you can learn how to do
anything on the [__] line
my friend told me to type in the knee
surgery they did
on me that you could see the surgery
being done i don't want to see that [__]
but i typed in how to play the [__]
guitar and i was blown the [__] away so
though i i watched three different
videos
and there was one long head guy real
dirty white guy kind of loved him he
looked like a junkie
i could tell at one time he was nodding
but his [__] videos are [__] good
and he could play so i watched his one
video and he said that for the first
week
all i want you to do is pick up the
guitar at night for one hour
and just play it and just get used to
handling it don't connect
to any amps or nothing you know the
first night i got an amp somewhere
i was gonna come in here and blow it up
hello cleveland you know about myself
but
i don't know how to do none of that
stuff but i think i needed a hobby and i
think
mike [__] solved the trick for me so
you know sometimes it takes somebody
else to [__]
figure out what you need in your life
sometimes you do need a little push so
for the first week i'm just going to sit
there at night for an hour
after my wife goes to bed it's a [__]
great guitar
i'm just going to play it with my little
pick and make believe i'm
keith richards every night i'm somebody
different so i've been doing it for
three nights now
the first thought i was keith richards
the second night i was david gilmour
and last night was jimmy page boy i was
a horrible jimmy page
tonight i'm tony naomi you know what i'm
saying
yeah i'm gonna have to cut my fingers
off and then friday i'm gonna be vivian
campbell
i got a different cam every night and
then monday by monday i'm gonna have my
first lesson i think
online and then i'm gonna dress up with
the suit like that one guitar player
wears a suit with short hair he's
[__] great what's his name jack white
no no i don't know what his name is he
wears a [__] like an 800
suit [__] no
not prince [__] that's next wednesday
i'm going to be prince
i'm going to do sign of the times by
myself
i'm going to have to have somebody play
the base here boom boom boom
by themselves but you know listen this
is a secret passion of mine
for years listen when you see ten
comedians
five of them are failed musicians okay
that's the other way around too
and it's the other way around too so i
never
that i failed as a musician
no i played the band
but we let lip sync we were like
we were like kiss in 1975.
so we would put dressed up no come on
mike you know be better than that
not like kids no no no we just wore
jeans and sneakers and converse sneakers
and
i was the lead singer because my voice
hadn't changed yet so i had a good voice
and my man dean lapreet played the
guitar my other buddy john played the
bass
and my man ray canelo who i still talked
to played the [__] drums
his father was a jazz drummer so we
would meet over his house every day what
i remember the most about the canelo's
was that
his mother used to have salsa so you
would put kool-aid in the class and use
the salsa to make kool-aid
god damn that [__] is good i used to
drink
every time i go and i make 19 of those
[__] kool-aids with salsa
i'd be fighting for two [__] days
after that i was in a band we didn't
have a name
we were preparing to play in the school
thing so what we did was like
uh dean really did play the guitar and
john was like
a beginning bass player and ray was a
[__] great drummer
and i was a great singer you know i had
that michael jackson quality to me you
know what i'm saying
yeah i really did so our first song that
we sang was helped by the beatles
the only album we did was help by the
beatles the whole
soundtrack whatever so we would sing the
whole album with the album one
and then we try to do it without the
album on it was a [__] disaster
so every band we played
every pan we played we break two needles
the three of
us but we're not the beatles anyway
you call me you can call me c whatever
the [__]
you could call me dmc i don't [__]
know what are we talking about the band
so this is what [__] happened with
the band all right we were doing great
we were in the sixth grade
every day we rehearsed i was on fire i
was like [__]
what was his name when you see the
motley crew movie the dirt
oh yeah yeah like when they kneel neil
whatever his name is
when they first got him that was me dog
i was [__] hot and [__] in the sixth
grade
in the sixth grade mr levito used to let
me go up in front of the class every
friday
and sing my eyes adored you by frankie
valli in the four seasons
so every [__] friday i would be a
crooner i would dress up like with a
shirt
with my big [__] ears and i'd sing my
eyes adored you
and girls would go take a walk get away
from us like [__] girls hated me
i would make believe like i was a
criminal i can [__] the godfather
though i never laid a hand on you my
eyes
adored you get the [__] out of here
so i started doing that so they were
like you could sing
you should join our band we're looking
for a lead singer so i was like [__] it
i'm in
so i showed up down there we rehearsed
like a month dawg have you ever played
the school
listen to wait till the [__] zinger
here
so we kept doing it doing it doing it
but
we didn't want to do a beetle we didn't
we didn't want to do all beetle songs
like all of us weren't into the [__]
beatles we like
we all voted on help
i need somebody to help not just anybody
help
you know i need someone hell when i was
younger so much younger than today
all that [__] i love that i loved all
that [__]
but the rest of that i didn't dig so we
had a vote
right we were like what other songs do
you want to add
dean was an animal you know dean lapreet
my boy
he was an animal and so was ray they had
older brothers
so they were showing up with steppenwolf
you know they were showing up with all
that [__]
and i'm learning the lyrics i remember
stepping wolf's
uh oh we another song i'm gonna play
tonight i forget i forgot to
we wake up every morning on a long
clocks morning take the 8th
15th to the city
it's taking care of business every day
taking care of business
so we got into that but the bass player
didn't want to play that
he was like we either do beatles or i
quit
and we're like god damn it we're just
getting going on
uh whatever taking care of business
the one born to be wild okay
uh they had older older brothers so like
they their music
tastes well not like i think i don't i
don't know if they showed up with led
zeppelin i'd love to lie to you and tell
you they did
but no i would love to lie to you it was
steppenwolf born to be wild
that's who sang it uh taking care of
business
the other song that they had that was
also big was give me your money please
and help and then we weren't gonna
switch it up you know they had more
ideas
in the sixth grade if you notice when i
do the album of the week i don't talk
about the sixth grade i wasn't really
you know i wasn't really too i was into
pop music in the sixth grade i knew
i know who el john was i know you know
uh love yeah love to love you baby don't
mention donnie and marie please
that [__] donny osmond calls me more
[__] in the seventh grade than anybody
that [__] [__] blocking [__] i
lived through donnie
then i got caught with [__] that
[__] office and the gentleman
richard gere he [__] my [__] up for
years
forget it i'm not even talking about you
[__] no more
so we were gonna expand and play but
john didn't
he just want to do beatles he was a
legitimate beat a middle fan and he
still is
and i loved him for it but we're like
john we want to expand he got all david
on us
so we had a vote and we voted him out
of the band and then we continued but we
couldn't find the bass player there was
only one other bass player
but this kid was just too heavy like not
fat like he wasn't fat no no
no no no oh yeah in the sixth grade he
already had long hair
he already had like a [__] mustache
like a beard you know he was one of
those sixth graders
he was already like dating like girls he
had groupies and [__]
he was a tremendous guitar player and
the bass player like he could do
whatever the [__] you wanted
so we were going to team him up and he
said you know we'll do two guitars on
one song
or one bass or whatever but he couldn't
keep it together i think he started glue
like he was doing whatever that drug
wasn't whatever was big in the 70s
that kids were doing he was doing was
either glue or sniffing toothpaste
and he wouldn't show up for [__]
rehearsals and [__]
so he [__] fired him but i'm gonna
tell you an interesting story and we'll
close with this
when my mother died guess whose family
took me in
john the bass player we fired
yes there was no heart that were hard
feelings still hard feelings but
uh he had a heart and he
at that age he was a good man he's still
a good man and uh
he decided it was his father but that's
really weird that we voted him out of
the band
and four years later i'm living with him
in this [__] house
life has a [__] weird way of [__]
showing up and kicking you in the
stomach
and that's it for this week wednesday
the 24th
of february i want to thank you guys for
watching
uh uncle joey's joint for [__]
always being there for us for supporting
us you know we got your back
don't forget tonight there's a great
[__] game on i think it's memphis
against new orleans i think that's what
it is
if you if you're not [__] around with
draftkings tonight's a good [__] game
it's a good line
the line is a little [__] up take a
look at it on draftkings tonight
it's going to be a [__] great game
and uh that's it and that's that
it's been a [__] full [__] week i
got [__] to do with people to see
but uh i really learned a really big
[__] lesson sunday that
i just your mind is too [__] strong
sometimes don't let your mind
throw that old negative [__] on you you
know we could all throw pity parties we
could all throw pity parties
but i refuse to and i'm happy i did
i'm happy that i don't throw pity
parties in my mind anymore
that was a bad thing to do and uh
i have my daughter back and that's all
that matters if my older daughter
ever wants to come into my life she's
always welcome
always welcome whatever happened between
us i could care less i love them more
today than i ever loved
uh life just doesn't uh
always work out the way you wanted to so
you have to adjust to it yourself
and take what they give you and be
grateful and that's what i'm doing right
now every day
especially with uncle joey's joining
with you guys
so uh thank you for watching thank you
for patreon
thank you for being here and i'm sorry
if the patreon
podcast was [__] up today i hi i want
to welcome cara
to our staff she's going to be helping
my niece is going to be helping me on uh
on patreon she's a college student she
just made the honor roll
and there's no jobs by her where she's
going to school up in rochester
so i just told her father you know her
father george is like my brother
he took me in in 1985
and here we are and we're still friends
and uh
so i wanted to repay the favor so she's
on our new patreon uh
payroll also thanks to you guys so thank
you very much for watching the joint
i love you guys don't forget to support
our sponsors
cbd lion expressvpn
draftkings relief band cbd lion i don't
give all of them
give them all the love and respect they
deserve use code joey on it
respect them all i love you guys have a
great week
thank you very much for being here and
we'll see you monday morning tip
top [__] magoo all right i want
to thank you [__] savages
for putting up with my [__] on
another beautiful wednesday
it's going to be a great week it always
is but before i go
i want to mention two things to you
number one cbd lion
number one in my book solid i know them
i know these guys personally i know how
much they put into that product
i know how much they they're just proud
because the product they have
is [__] superior to everybody else's
whether it's the tincture the gummy
bears the bath ball
the kinesiology tape the kinesiology
role i mean listen
they're bringing it to you from all
[__] directions they're like the
gambinos in the 80s they're not [__]
around
do me a favor right now why would you
buy [__] cbd at a gas station
why why are there i drive up in jersey i
go to get gas i go inside to get rolling
papers
they got [__] cbd at a gas tank would
you
who raised you go to cbdline.com right
now
preston joey and get 20 off delivered
right to your house get your cbd life
started today
read about cbn read about cbd read about
cby
they got a bunch of [__] cbs with
numbers but read about them but it all
starts by you going to cbd
lion present joey
the joint is also brought to you by
expressvpn listen like i tell you the
beginning
when you're in the bathroom doing your
thing you close the door you don't leave
the door open
so people could look at you what what
are you at a museum
now using the internet without
expressvpn that's like going to the
bathroom and not closing the door
do you want do you know that creepy
internet providers actually spy on what
you do
every single [__] website you visit
that's why i tape that hole over the
computer
and then they turn around and sell your
info to an ad company
you ever [__] go for a plane ticket
you let's say you put in i'm going from
la to houston
and ever since you put it in after that
for hours that's all the ads you got
plane tickets for houston
ah that [__] wouldn't happen with
expressvpn
expressvpn puts to stop this [__]
madness
it creates a secure tunnel between you
and the internet
no one can see what you're up to it's
between you and the big man upstairs
that's it
it all works on all devices and on wi-fi
covers everyone in your home and it's an
easy to use as closing the bathroom door
just push one button and you're
protected that's it that's why
expressvpn
is rated number one i don't [__] around
i'm not gonna show up with some
susquehanna products
i sus i show up with the real [__]
deal for you people why
because i love you you're here with me
in the grinders i'm here with you in the
grind
so if you're like me and you like
looking at creepy [__] things from
time to time
believe me your online security is your
business secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com joey
and they're going to give you an extra
three months free
free free so support the joint and
protect your privacy
at expressvpn.com joey
i love you [__] have a great
week i'll see you
uh next wednesday at uncle vinnie's
right
tonight tonight uncle venice yeah i'm an
uncle vinnie's tonight
and all through march i love you
[__] have a great week and i'll
see you
monday morning
you